I have Elizabeth here with me in the
studio Elizabeth welcome back hi uh you
made the draw today with black against
Irina crash please tell me how did you
come up with this idea of playing H6
against Irina well actually it was not
my idea I wanted to play something else
and then I was discussing like all the
evening along with with my coach and
then he wanted something totally
different and I wanted something totally
different and then he came up with this
idea and I said like fine because
actually our goal was to get Arena out
of the opening very quickly and just to
play on ourselves and actually with H6 I
think I managed
okay so what did you expect did you
expect the move Bishop Bishop F4 is
normal but what is unusual is actually
like that she played E4 I mean after
Bishop takes c626 E4 that is unusual
because I mean like compared to this
line with um where you sacrifice a Pawn
on D4 here a lot of pieces are already
exchanged so
um the thing is like that she must be
careful about the D4 Pawn on the long
run and I even thought I I was not
better here but I thought it might be
dangerous for her but then actually
um I'm not sure where I went wrong
because before was needed because if she
doesn't play before I will go A5 Knight
C6 long Castle Knight F5 and then this
Pawn
might be very tricky
um well the default Pawn might not be a
nice fellow
to say the least long Castle but after
before I thought like that okay I mean I
understood that maybe I'm not better
here even so I should see that the
engine likes this position but yes
Knight F3 was played a five B5 maybe A5
was wrong but I didn't really know what
to do actually in this position I didn't
even know whether I wanted to play F5
and King F7 or short Castle or long
castle level so many choices and it's
always tough when women have a lot of
choices because you can never decide
um yeah so uh here I was very happy
because here I saw like that maybe even
like it's getting a bit tricky for me
because I don't have ideas but when she
played Knight eating too I was very
happy because I got this kind of
free move of C5 to get the space back
and here I think the position is around
equal I don't think that the game was
anything special or we missed some
chances any of us so here I was already
like happy that we can maneuver around
but nobody really can do much because if
she pushes she should get weak squares
and if I push I get weak squares and
here it's the same you know I was
thinking even like after Rook C7
in the end to play on but I understood
that even after for example like King C3
she played and here I mean if I want to
play on I have to play something like
Knight p8
a knight E8 I didn't even see oh not be
it so I know it is
this move actually was not coming to my
mind just during the night 26.
yeah I mean I felt like that might be
something here but I only saw like
Knight p8 Knight E5 and then it was
nothing but 98 I just I think I just
missed in a way that this was possible
maybe you were already happy that with
the draw here it's not like happy I was
feeling that it might be more than that
but I mean in this position if I had
played on I would have played Knight B8
so actually 98 for some reason didn't
cross my mind I don't not sure why maybe
after 98 I thought like something like
94.
and then you don't get to 96 but then
probably you use the other night yes
maybe ah yes this doesn't work here yes
no an idea item is actually
I didn't think about that one
Elizabeth do you have your favorite
chest word because I know that Yasser
certainly has one so what would be your
favorite Chess World oh I don't even
know I mean
um something like tuition sug this is
yes sir's favorite word but German that
it's kind of boring
so actually uh I'm not sure what is my
favorite chessboard I never thought
about that I just would I never thought
about it but it's definitely not side
note that's Vision soup it's just
happened to be German and English
language doesn't have that word I guess
so not sure actually okay so it's
something to think about Elizabeth I
wanted to ask you about your upcoming
events because I know that there is a
new tournament which is going to take
place in July June July I think the
global chess League can you tell us
something about it yes this is a new
kind of format which was invented by
Tech Mahindra and Vita Tech Mahindra is
a
uh is a company from India and they got
this idea of a global chest leak which
is equal like to the Champions League in
football I mean kind of this sort of
style they composed to teams now and
actually I happen to be in the team with
um Irena but the funny part is like
we're on the team with the strongest
guys in the junior section and in the
world rankings so cool it's my first
time to play with Magnus on a team but
it's like on the one hand it's very good
on the other hand like I remember his
faces from the Nova from the Olympiad in
Chennai and sometimes he didn't look
abused when he was checking the other
boards so this kind of you know face you
you happen to remember from from the
past is is a little bit scary but
actually the funniest part was I did
some calculations yesterday and I
realized that I like that the age of
Irina and me together could be actually
almost equal to everybody else
so that means actually we are not only
the uh crannies on the team we also
could be mothers in that team and that's
something which is is like yeah it's
unusual but
um yes we could be basically the mother
of kukash of arigasi of Prague so it's
it's sort of funny to have like such a
young team and the two old grannies
combined so that's sort of funny how
many players are playing from this
tournament that are playing in the
global chest League um I think it's
Alexandra then it's Nana it's Bella and
humpy
and now I'm puzzled I think
um that's it's those so far almost the
whole field you know the strongest
players in the world so well it will
certainly be a very exciting event to
watch thank you very much Elizabeth and
the next time well you have to prepare
an answer for the question yes I will I
will think about it
thank you Elizabeth as we are looking at
the game between
[Music]